le procès de la sphère du transpalette a
été reporté aux 28 et 29 octobre
la raison la demande de la défense des
prévenus en raison de la grève des
avocats
cinq prévenus aurait dû être jugé pour
vols et dégradations aggravées il avait
défoncé la porte en tout cas participer
à défoncer la porte du secrétariat
d'état du porte parole du gouvernement à
l'époque benjamin griveaux qui avait dû
être exfiltré en réalité des cinq
prévenus aucun n'a pénétré dans la cour
du porte parolat mais il encourt jusqu'à
sept années d'emprisonnement
alors finalement donc cette demande de
renvoi a été acceptée par la présidente
fait rare les avocats de la partie
civile se sont joints à cette demande de
renvoi je vous propose d'écouter
bérenger tourné l'avocat d'un des
prévenus
ben c'est l'ensemble des confrères
présents que ce soit la partie civile
d'ailleurs et la défense réunie qui ont
demandé le report de cette affaire j'ai
de toute façon n'était pas en état
d'être jugé puisque la présidente a bien
compris qu'il faudrait plus d'une après
midi d'audience pour pour être compliqué
pour instruire cette affaire qui n'a pas
donné lieu à des instructions
parce que le parquet a décidé de faire
vite de faire mal et à trop vouloir
faire vite et bien il va finir par avoir
une affaire qui d'une comparution
immédiate le lendemain ou le
surlendemain des faits
va souffrir un délai de plus d'un an et
demi maintenant puisque c'est renvoyé je
crois au 28 octobre prochain
gilet jaune jérôme rodriguez et faouzi
lellouche était venu assister à
l'audience en soutien aux prévenus
il voit dans cette affaire les prémices
des grèves d'aujourd'hui je vous propose
de les écouter
il était important qu'on vienne les
soutenir parce que ce qu'on défend
depuis 16 mois c'est les prémices de
toutes les contestations sociales qui
peut y avoir aujourd'hui dont la demande
principale des avocats d'avoir renvoyé
cette affaire justement dieu à la grève
aussi des avocats
il est important de soutenir nos
collègues malgré peut-être les méfaits
donc ils sont accusés et je pense que
c'est important pour eux comme pour
beaucoup aujourd'hui de gilet jaune qui
passe en conclure à sion immédiate ou
qui passent devant un tribunal de se
sentir soutenu d'avoir des copains
derrière et d'essayer ne serait-ce que
malgré sa demande un petit peu plus
humaine la justice on ayant des gens
derrière eux il faut noter que ce procès
a déjà été renvoyé quatre fois et pas à
la demande des avocats des prévenus
ce qui signifie qu'un an et demi après
les faits les auteurs vont enfin être
fixés sur leur sort